you got to understand you cannot change
somebody else you can budget them you
can threaten them you can guilt them but
at the end of the day it is up to the
person that you're with to decide
whether or not he or she is going to
change that said you can do things that
influence whether or not they want to
and so the most important thing with
personal development now remember what's
the key word in personal development
it's personal is you continue to do you
you continue to read the books you
continue to hang out with the people
that inspire you you continue to push
your life forward you continue to go to
the gym and the thing that you're going
to do is you're going to share a lot
with your partner you're going to share
about what you're learning you're going
to share about who you're hanging out
with you're going to share about all
these cool distinctions and tools that
you're learning you're going to share
about the things that scare you you're
going to open up in a way that impacts
your relationship